yes Ricky has come and Ricky it's good
to see you Rick
just before we we were just talking in
the bed when the break was ending about
you did shoot your special and how hard
it is to shoot the special then go out
and you torque is now all the shows
after are even better because that whoa
is they get better anyway you think of
little things you revisit it you're
relaxed because you know where that's in
the can yeah and then you start thinking
ah we shot a tape that night I wish a
tape tonight but then it'd be the same
because I've never I've never taped a
special when it was probably the best
gig of the tour you know it's written
out how can you do that yeah it's in the
ballpark it's fine it's good so one of
the better ones I think so I think so
and I did it at the end of a longer the
longest run you know I did it at the end
of like 14 in London so it's there yeah
but um you just are you just act
differently when you're being filmed
you're being observed yeah you think it
did I do that was that fast or slow was
that slower it was that good was that
wasn't you know and anyone else they
couldn't tell the difference but the
only way to do it is to film everyone
and not be told someone's filming it
yeah then you then you got all you film
tonight Oh tonight was amazing
thank God I know wondering where that
guy was either he was trying to shoot me
that was a camera he was holding on it
unless you get really egotistical and
you put out a DVD boxset of the entire
tour yes because you like there's little
differences that I yeah everybody should
see all the shows that's a great idea
yeah I've done 28 Netflix special 28
specials this year hey when you are the
worst when you start writing tag lines
for stuff that's already been shot or
were you started improving on bits like
that's the worst do you film that you
can't redo it all of a sudden you think
of like another minute a half for a bit
you know like Alf I wouldn't [ __ ] it
feels old I already think I'm still I'm
talking about stuff that are without you
know a year ago but actually because the
stuff I deal with isn't isn't that
topical it isn't stuff that happened
yesterday it's sort of you know big
iconic things I don't think it will date
right as much you know if you do a
topical show and the more topical summer
is the more it dates they don't know you
know so you know when you're dealing
with aids famine the Holocaust
you know those things last yeah thank
God for that with the comedy they're
endless they're always good Hitler is
what's known as evergreen I did I did
Berlin and I got a big Hitler bit I
always have and there's always someone
new to say about and I started it and it
was Berlin and I went let's talk about
Hitler and it went better than anywhere
else really knows because they go all
good someone's not skirting the issue
someone's not packed like I think people
think they're going to bring a girl
almost and talk about hip though he's
probably a bit of a hero they're like a
lot of the Nazi stuff is totally illegal
like you'd like wait huh you can't do
the Hitler salute with us what did you
reason I stopped taking the piss out of
Hitler because you know you have the
night to hail a cab yeah I know I did it
and it's in context and but it's a whole
generation it's it's like you are you
still embarrassed by Nixon cause you're
not enough something Nixon you go okay
dude it still hurts but you know let's
not bring up it cares Nixon he ever did
Nixon wasn't quite your you shouldn't
feel guilty about the deeds of your
forefathers you know you should
acknowledge them and but um it's it's
not you know you did with these people
weren't born it's all your fault
no although we are still very sensitive
about slavery in the United States yeah
that's one of those topics that are like
if you're gonna joke about slaver you
gotta be really really careful Wow yeah
no that's true of any sort of terrible
thing that happened you should be
careful but when you say we you mean
collectively you as a as a historic
government you don't mean you see how
these people are employees exactly you
know so yeah but yeah I was my favorite
tour it's nearly over my favorite to all
my favorite special easily we have you
back on the road or do you like to like
relax I honestly can't wait I can't wait
for this to be over because I've already
got a bag of ideas my next one and
that's never
and you know because I consider myself a
stand-up now you know it took 15 years
to get good that shouldn't be a
revelation but it does it took me 15
years to you know surprise surprise what
are you already starting the new
material you can start yeah how I want
to yeah for the first time ever I've
started making notes as well for like 20
years if I come up with something funny
that me it would just go you know I
didn't write it down and dictaphone I
don't um and then come the time I better
do a special I say you know what have I
said that's funny
so yeah I've already got like I could go
out and do you know a warm a 10-minute
warmup um but I just can't wait why
don't you hire a guy just to film you
like with a GoPro and that will hire
someone just to write down the stuff you
say like not to improve on and or fix it
but just to jot down the trace you have
like mostly now I do it now I do a send
a little email to myself and I've got a
little bag of things so I I do do it and
it's you know it's it's really light and
I don't want to write it because I think
that's what I did with the first four
specials I sort of wrote them like an
Edinburgh show or a lecture or something
and then went and sort of did them like
an actor and with humanity I wandered
out on the stage with a couple of things
written on the back of my hand and it
you might arrive at the same place but
the process is different is more organic
and it's really and it I think it I just
think it resonates more I think you can
tell the difference my memory stinks
that I have to I talked up into my
iPhone all the time my memory is so bad
that I look at my phone go [ __ ] I forgot
this i forgot that like i forget half my
stuff it's just one it's usually one
idea but then this is the biggest
revelation i found out if you spend a
hundred hours write in something you've
still got to do it it don't give you it
doesn't give you any advantage right
whereas if you spend 100 hours
practicing something in front of an
audience that is gonna fly you could
start with [ __ ] and after a hundred
hours of just saying it and you know cut
into the laughs you'll have a great show
whereas you don't know when you write
something you still got to be you know
it's it's to be performed you spend all
those hours writing and writing and
reading okay it's finally ready and then
you get up in front of an audience and
it sucks what it won't it won't work
right great is the greatest jokes ever
written done the first time are not as
good as
pores jokes done a hundred times and
honed and they're just it's just not you
can laugh at the concept and you know
there's something there but it's it's
it's the it's being ring fit it's the
you know your eye on the ball is its it
is practice you it's hard like I to keep
the emote like I had in my apartment
flooded recently stars talking about on
stage and for the first unite because I
still had the emotion attached to it I
was all [ __ ] up about it I was nervous
about it and it rang true yeah then it's
like two weeks later I had to chop it
down a little cuz some parts of it I
just couldn't muster up the energy to
pretend this is real well I can do that
and but it's still when it first happens
the first time we say somewhat like an
ad-lib right the next night you try and
do it's not as good but then it gets you
can get it as good again by just you
know you've got a trust I think you've
gotta trust the words and the practice
it's like a science it either works oh
it doesn't
yeah I turn in that trusted yeah I know
you mean I've got that guilt thing I
think if I'm am i lying they can like
enough I can feel guilty that I've lied
to them so I try and get more and more
honest that's what I do know it's like
if the laughs is coming from a lie
you're cheating yeah yeah and I have cut
out like jokes that you know that are
obviously lies or surreal or something
because I don't think the true stories
aren't true right right so when I say
some it's true it really is the obvious
lies feel embarrassing they're like the
ones that like you know I was doing
there something like think you were you
know when you can really tell that as
well it's when um comedians who use
writers right where they go so I was on
that
no you won't I can tell already you want
yeah I can tell already they wanna look
at giant celebrities they can't me and
the other day I was on the subway and
it's like you yeah well exactly yeah so
I have to embrace the fact that they
know I'm probably not signing on welfare
and I'm taking two brides and you know I
mean I speak to your truth not any truth
of like let me let me go from their
perspective yeah audience like well I
think even it even if it's a great
observation like um isn't it funny when
you know if you say this is a true story
my sister I'm already engaged if this if
I think this really happened right
that's better than the nebulous isn't it
funny when yeah you know it's sort of
like it's not
I don't know I want that real one small
story it's funny to know that something
actually happened to a person as opposed
to oh this guy is just good at coming up
with concepts you know yeah yeah like
that because there's nothing funnier
than a thing happening to a person also
it's harder to be ripped off as well if
you do general observations or puns
anyone can just take it and use it as if
it's really your story that's really
hard to rip off yeah you know I mean the
coincidence is too great we were to get
hold on that's what happened to
so-and-so that's that's not yours I also
find to when I'm doing real thoughts or
real stories a lot of times it's harder
to find like the Big Bang punchline
because like a true story and a lot of
times in life the punchline doesn't end
what occurred so a lot of times the
[ __ ] great funny part of it there's
still like a minute and a half left of
true story yeah I suppose you want it to
be lean as well don't you yeah get more
out of it but is that the best you know
laughs per unit time you want to get a
good average don't you yeah and I think
sometimes you want to leave him on a on
a high no and it's great yeah yeah and
start again in a flood story nobody
wants to hear and then the super came up
and luckily it was the pipe so it's a
building issue so interesting as a
person yeah the people are gonna laugh
at your joke and then go no Jim but what
happened to the pipe you're like they're
gonna walk out as homeowners insurance
of the building for chrissake I'm always
I'm always fascinated when people can
tell you how to go and it is not as an
anecdote it's not a story I go I went
the shops right I thought I'd um I
thought I'd run out of cereal right so
and then look I didn't know I didn't
have to go in the end why have you told
me that why you told not a story doesn't
need to ever to be told right it
happened once to you know people tell
you their dreams right a weird dream
known to you to me nothing yeah it
doesn't matter
it can't it's not interesting to me no
weird that's just like saying hey you
want to hear a thing I just made hey do
you want to hear a thing I just made up
yeah
well the worst is when somebody writes
in poetry and they want that you know
they want to share their yelling out and
working on this poem Oh Oh honestly
someone did but poetry once right it was
a friend of a friend and it was around
my place right and it's an opportunity
so I think gonna be interesting it and
he told it to me right and and it was so
intense right and James the next room
and she said she could feel me cringing
it was the worst most pretentious sort
of twenty three-year-old poem I could
say who it was I kind of members now
might but it ended with right there I
think of his finger the poem that this
ends with poor Bert
poor Bert that's how it ended poor bird
because poor bird is such a heavy
statement after what he's told you know
like let that sink in I'll say it again
the embarrassing things what do you
think of this yeah you have to lie
though it's it's it's you know it is
hard to be honest and tell someone like
your inner thoughts your inner poetry
and artist is garbage it's hard to tell
how you don know you can't because woody
interesting yeah no it's cute lexicon
Excalibur could they stab you with my
cocky intense it because that's what I
want it was what that's what was intense
about it that that it's like some of my
poetry and it's just too intense is too
too close and tell me over the phone go
away call me from a call box write and
tell me the poem because I can't have
you in the room but what you just said
it's like a dead giveaway when you
respond to the poem by saying Amen
that's good keep at it as opposed to
actually talking about the poem oh now
he's it's a ship home well what I wanted
to do was go please leave I want to kill
you I want to kill you for making me sit
through that was it it was you know what
it was probably like 16 lines right but
the
when someone looking at you as their
tailor and order and all they're all the
emotions about themselves someone told
you emotions about something as a poem
about me what went through all [ __ ] me
let's forget it let's know you're
embarrassed for them I'm embarrassed for
them and I can't and that's what I can't
cope with I can I'm not embarrassed for
me I'm always embarrassed for other
people I admire people who don't have
that I mean a lot of times they're
called sociopaths people who are not
embarrassed for other people I envy them
so much because they're more honest and
they say themselves a lot of grief yeah
and [ __ ] because they don't they
don't do those socially honorable things
I don't hear it are the number of times
that I've I'm probably gonna have a
heart attack will those little bits of
adrenaline and feeling bad for someone
and cringing for them that that's all
mountian up and that it's probably taken
about a year off my life
yeah over the years of all those and the
worst thing is if you're in a group of
people and everyone's like making a joke
and then someone makes a crap joke and
you got all there's nothing you know
when you laughing so much I think I'm
never gonna stop laughing this is
someone making a slightly crap joke and
that kills it this is calling a man on
earth oh if it's the situation we're out
it feels fun though it can be tiring in
here when you [ __ ] jump on some rich
vos or somewhere in front of me I know
that's the guy sure yeah yeah and you
know I grew up with that but it's all I
can't take it now I can't I feel so I
don't want anyone to go through pain
kind of laughing and like smiling and
just trying to go along with it and just
moving the conversation along but every
time Jim and me or just look at each
other like did Vash just say no I know
but I can't I don't want to confront
them and as he's about example cuz he's
really funny yeah and I know you're
teasing him yeah but that you know in a
group when someone is the isn't funny
into intensity we talked this morning I
came in I'm I'm historically and this is
me being a codependent where I'm very
very bad at small talk I don't know if
you're good at it I'm awful at I hate it
but I have to do it again to save them
you know I mean if cashier says cold and
I don't to go [ __ ] off ball you know I
gotta go easy as murder doing it off so
she'll get better by
you have to do it and you feel you know
but it is bailing them out from the
honest moment of knowing well but but
somebody needed to bail Jim out because
we could speak about this conceptually
but when your response is even worse
than their awful because I'm bad at it I
mean that's what now I'm not excited
okay so I'm not gonna tell you
a security guard downstairs Jim came in
with his luggage today yeah and a
security guard downstairs What did he
say I don't want to carry my luggage and
he goes a bag of cash which is terrible
right it's not a good joke you a great
security guy you're a black belt in
jujitsu quite you great you've taken a
bullet mmm
but don't ever make a [ __ ] badge over
that again cuz you're out of here dude
[ __ ] right yeah I'd rather fight you
yeah Cassius I know but but right
go on well sometimes when you have 28
years of standing up to fall back on I
said I just panicked I have nothing I'm
telling he goes up baggie cash and I
went yeah payout for the guys I don't
know with you I too just stayed silent I
couldn't be they awkwardness I wouldn't
have wanted because I'd have known that
was over for you for the guys just
silence just just he gave me a paw and I
told him I who made the bad observation
was looking at Jim like why would you
respond like that I thought what I
should have just been honest like you
know have bag of cash
just some shoes and socks and like I
just told the truth well I used to I
used to work a friend of mine you know
that thing when you go with a suit right
and there was the poor and the poor I
would always say Oh been to a funeral
right sure and uh and my friend Glyn had
just been to a funeral just buried his
and he came in and but went up into a
funeral he went yeah he went one day
they are gonna pin to a funeral because
that was a joke responses King he's just
trying to get his light off yeah my
grandmother shot herself
and some people are masterful at that
little banter and it's a real social
lubricant and I'm [ __ ] I not I'm not
awful at it on purpose I just can't do
it I've never been able to do it
successful people usually know how to do
they probably do I know I've got that
little thing where I wasn't a judge
there once and they said oh he's lost a
lot of white how'd you do it I said I'd
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
rather I'm an re sentiment ya ask you
and you're saying that ripping people
off it reminded me have you watch black
mirror oh no I haven't but I've seen the
one about the body a couple of them no
Edward yeah I don't see that one show
there's Carl from you know from Ricky's
pocket yeah from the OL podcast
predicted episode black mirror like they
took or
or the people who make like mirror
fences well I think that's more like the
other thing that a wish that when you
went to the doctor the doctor could put
you in a thing and the doctor could feel
what you were feeling so he'd know cuz
it's hard to describe mine and that was
it so no how would that would this work
right he had other ideas like I said
I've invented some again what he said
see through skin well we can't do it you
can't say I've invented and then go oh I
don't know the details yet we just get
on with it
No so it's comenta stuff he came up with
so it was perfect for this but yeah I
didn't see it but everyone said I'm in
the middle of that one now actually the
doctor has the thing in this neck it's
really fascinating it's just funny cuz
on the on the YouTube video like they
take from the podcast in the animated
series and they show like the setup for
it and then they show it in the episode
and then they show like you and Steven
going like why would it do this and then
Karl explains this and then they show it
in the episode
yeah that's good yeah I just had a
medical right um every year right and
and I asked the doctor right why still
the finger and they've got they've got
now P Summit psi uh what's it called
where they can tell if you've got
prostate problems from a urine test it
went but that only one side of it where
you can tell if they start
it is early with it so the fingers never
going away the finger is never going
away
are you a crew you were saying why do
you do all this stuff they was taking
blood samples that was show everything
but then he said now God's doing the
finger we asked oh you said wife saw the
finger why steal the finger yeah and
it's just not going away they always
need they always need someone to feel it
first because it's early stage isn't
that so yeah and you can feel around in
there it's like there are some doctors
though that want to hold back some
technology because they really no I
think I think manually is the waited yes
well I'll go there every year and it's
always and this guy is a big guy as well
and I thought what he's gonna have a
[ __ ] huge finger yeah yeah I was
waiting for it and it's not it's not the
worst thing the testicles are worse now
as well because they seem to hurt more
than ever more sensitive or because I'm
thinking about it they sort of shrink so
he has to dig in now and get my balls
out of this thing drink up like a little
turtle going into the shower yeah
because I'm so nervous now about [ __ ]
the skin kind of hornet's nest yesterday
has to dig him out now I've heard about
like like somebody's dick like going
back in when they get nervous or cold or
whatever I've never heard of somebody's
testicles going back into their body it
must be the nervous reaction which is
odd because my testicles are longer and
stretchier than they've ever been but so
they should be easy I mean if you'd
probably do it know they were they were
shrunk so what how do you know I'm 49 so
you've got a starving the fingers oh
yeah great from the fist now I went for
colonoscopies recently when I was a
little young just to do it and make sure
everything was okay I'm paranoid about
that so yeah I get checked once a year
it's all good yeah that's good
apparently [ __ ] has an echo yeah good
point let me just take this off
Jim having things shoved up his ass
shouldn't be shoved up his ass that's
the three big ones
don't forget cancer pedophilia still on
the docket yeah it's one of those things
you just got to do it I'll leave him a
note I still it's still awkward though
it's just in awkward I saw my joke about
it and he said dumb no and can I give
you a I said yep yep let's do it like
that right right they'll talk about it
and he said them now do you need a
chaperone I went no and I went that'd be
worse I said it's bad enough what you do
it you do it but you've got a mate
watching now Shaun can you come in I'm
just gonna stick my finger over dad's
ass and he wants he wants someone
watching I didn't know I don't want
someone watching you said can average
this and that happened you should say
yes and when the guy comes in hand him
your iPhone you I'm 34 so you've never
had a doctor put his finger up there I
don't think you know
no no well yeah what did you start this
that is it fifty or before well I start
I think fifty I think so yeah because
the at fifty testicular cancer not much
of a problem anymore prostate cancer
here we come real it's a cross over on
the graph yeah when you're young it's
the other way wrestles don't worry about
the prostate right now now it's the
other way around so I think testicle
testicular cancer is easier to deal with
so has that is the best one together top
it out they can put a fake one any
because it's not it's not a problem
because I think it's pretty isolated it
might the difficult ones always like you
know liver as everywhere you're not I
mean I do he says what you worried about
I said um every cancer heart and lungs I
think are doing well but every cancer
things I you know what you know and he
went okay
I sound mad in front of a doctor because
I'm so honest yeah I go I wake up and
it's good and if I ever got a lump I say
I'm gonna die jack okay okay he must be
this is a mental case yeah but it's just
all like doctors I'm nervous I'm nervous
for that hour and I think I talk far
even I mean when that being sort of
examined I think if I talk they're not
gonna find anything wrong with me yeah I
mean okay I think I have to do is wait
out the out like putting off a teacher
you ask
tell us about your motorbike so before
you know it as the end the lesson
usually was taking my heart and I was
talking to you got a shut up he just
said this if you've got to shut up sorry
cuz I'm nervous
so let me when you are when you go for
something like that they have these like
executive physicals they cost a lot but
you can go with a that you spell it the
whole day where they can check you for
every type of cancer and I know someone
had that done um it's ten grand I think
and they put you in the machine and it
does it goes through your body and check
your everything you can't like Tron it's
just like you know you're in this thing
and it yeah absolutely everything lungs
heart you want blood work all that stuff
yeah cuz usually it's their specific
test so you can't have a blood test if
they don't find everything cuz I'm
looking for everything they're looking
for one thing that if a diabetes or
something but then
have to do it's like there's no one
there's like a hundred tests how often
do you have to go back though like once
you get the whole test everything
checked like are you good for 10 years
no well you're well you probably find
something wouldn't you that like even I
find they say things like oh yeah your
cholesterol it's just in the safe zone
but watch that or diabetes yeah you've
got a 3% chance but watch that you know
it's just like you're meant to do
something I never do know it's like I
know it doctor saying you should stretch
more you should probably cut down on
that wine I go I know the rules I said
I'm doing this on purpose I know I know
the rules like I want to say to a doctor
now what are you gonna do about it I'm
gonna carry on drinking too much wine
and eating too much cheese what are you
gonna do about you've got to save my
life without me giving up wine this is
your job give me a pill I can take or
something that will counterbalance my
shitty be exactly like well that's right
it's fun that's one of the fun things
about living right now that we've come
from so long with with presidents and
first ladies and stuff being obsessed
with nutrition and exercise and diet
yeah and this week the White House
doctor comes up and he goes you know the
president could stand to lose some
weight but he doesn't like to diet or
exercise that guy that poor doctor was
forced out there to say out how fit and
tall he is it looked like a hostage
video didn't it his mouth was dry he was
looking to the left I'm just imagining a
gun coming in and going oh he's really
fit and tall
he's toys-r-us excited for his high he's
perfect I mean I want that doctor people
didn't notice the sweating that was
happening there I know wearing it was so
ridiculous apparently if he's if they do
the stats that equation to his actual
height which is 6 foot 2 he comes out as
a beast
yes yes driver's license exactly yeah 6
3 entering the White House so I think at
63 he's one pound shy exactly of being
obese yeah which congratulations so will
I be 6 for 3 when I'm 70 then
cuz I because I you get obviously get
talks generally what happens yeah I know
but I do I do if there was some of that
sort of pail right you took a pill and
they
and then for an hour you were you've
shat and vomited and you bled from every
and then they scraped you off and you
were clean wouldn't that be great
absolutely time flowers yeah it was like
every yeah and they just they just came
at you it was like you know somewhat of
a horror film and then then you were
fine for a wine you were real fine it
was just to be amazing so I've invented
that then the pillow makes you [ __ ] and
violet and bleed for an hour speaking of
which I'm performing in science and I
was great thank you it was really great
the your recommendation was in that
place I did two shows in London one in
Dublin and one in Manchester I [ __ ]
love it that's made three great places
there because the Manchester's always
good Dublin is incredible isn't it it's
like it's a Saturday night every night
of the way isn't it except Saturday and
that's like new easy yeah it's amazing
I met a guy I was tired I met a guy
walking he yelled Jim Norton it was a
big jam in Jim and Sam Shoen I'm looking
for a place to eat he goes hop in so I
just hopped into a stranger's truck in
Dublin and he drove me to a place to eat
it was so bizarre no she didn't didn't
like it because even no one speaks for
the first half an hour but don't you
love that we just went from like I was
so nervous because the security guard
said hello - yeah I was in a foreign
country and another continent yeah and
some guy in a truck asked if I wanted to
jump in yeah and I jumped in yeah but it
was a fun I loved loved him and I loved
it over there was so much fun the gigs
were great it was the same as you're a
trusting guy did you do an old show do
you haven't done there no I just did the
current set that I'm doing I didn't do
it's on Netflix I did the currents that
I'm doing all right right is my just my
current hour any oh and it's when you
say current hour you've worked that up
to an hour which you do now I think
times are reverting again now because
between sort of DVDs sort of finding a
little bit and Netflix dominating the
universe it was all about gigging again
but now it's now it's like gig until you
can get your special on and then start
again yeah by the time I'm ready I won't
shoot I probably made a hopefully shoot
within the next year at some point but I
get so bored I don't want to do the
material anyway so I love
just get it on filming and just drop it
I'm done as soon as it on film I'm done
I mean there's really something lovely
about having an hour with no pressure
that you can do a gig tomorrow if
someone that's cause you're sure you
know I mean no you cannot I used it once
of my hours up you know me and Jane just
had a little holiday for the weekend I
play that arena in Copenhagen and we had
a weekend in coconut you know I mean it
was just lovely licensed to just fly
around the world and so they did India
gigs pay for your vacation basic oh god
yeah but I mean even a warm-up would
really if you think the the relative
cost how many people pay paying that to
a flight in a hotel sure I could do it I
could go there for you know warm ups in
400-seat as if I wanted to so it is a
amazing I don't know not skill set but
an amazing asset to have the fact that
you're a working comedian and you can
just pop up and play wherever you want
it's incredible it is and I've been
branching out and doing a lot more
places and I finally did I said bill
burr got in my ear and I credit him a
lot and you were in my ear and there's a
whole bunch of people to just try it
just do it and it was great I can't
whack to London in a second well the
next thing I think you've done it as
well but my new discovery over the last
year's is Scandinavia that are there
first of all their English is better
than ours yes they're there every plus
Stockholm Copenhagen Oslo regular it's
there they're beautiful it's affluent
they're liberal they're arty they're up
for it they go out it's honestly it's
like it's a dream for a comedian I think
I didn't drive I did okay and I was
lower to draw I did the one shot I
almost canceled trying to be the best
one which was Copenhagen turned out to
be the best show and I was like yeah I
loved it it sold last minute it was it
was the best show I did out of that
entire really I've played that before
and after he's probably one of my
favorite places in the world now they're
conditioning in Europe though the hotels
don't you going in the summer a lot of
them are older buildings I'd say we go
there conditioning he goes into the
Sistine Chapel and goes a bit warm in
here absolutely look at the ceiling dude
bit warm in here
I'm a gentleman who requires air
conditioning environment I know I stayed
in a couple of places in the summer in
England and you wouldn't think that was
a problem but it is you know we do get
up to the nineties now and again and
when you're staying in like castles or
these stately homes
you can't complain there's no academic
buildings that I know he's architectural
amazing exactly and I get so hot that I
know I know that what the Wi-Fi out what
did Henry the eighth's do for Wi-Fi you
have files here just regular cable I
actually stayed in a room that Henry the
eighth's stayed in when the castle was
seven years old I played a stateless
place called Thornbury Castle when I had
his room and it's a real fire in this
four-poster bed and I was and I was
thinking yeah but you do [ __ ] Louise
great bid on a you're in a chair in the
sky about fly exactly but I've caught
myself so many times wanting to complain
about the Wi-Fi or whatever I'm like
technically he's I you go back to that
bit it's one of those busy you just keep
going back to oh yeah he's right I know
the thing that curbs me now I do want to
complain about the slightest thing I am
spoil and I talked about it in humanity
right but being famous curbs that
because I don't want to be on YouTube
complaining all right I don't want to
hear one gossip thing about me oh it was
a bit of RC so I'm really I can't
complain anymore
and I also think no that's holding us
hostage it is I think it's also stopping
us from acting like total [ __ ] half
the time too I know of what exactly and
I think I think that's that's good yeah
it might it does if anything that makes
you a better person you know some people
think God's watching them you know and I
know I know YouTube is watching me I
don't take the dose in the soup back I
also think that um I got that age where
now I think that they could be having a
bad day if a way of drive or someone
makes a mistake he could have just found
out is [ __ ] wife's got counts or
summer and I'm going well that never
mind that there's no reason to be like
you know I mean later at the end of the
day I know that's your family life
playing devil's advocate that is sad
news but there's no reason you should
have cold soup exactly if she smiles
it's funny when you're in the moment
you're not rational you just think why
me
right why me were you here were you ever
an [ __ ] before the internet was quite
so prevalent like would you have your
moments no because again III didn't I
didn't feel privileged I never felt I
never thought whether I deserve more
than then he went out obviously I do now
yeah you know I'd never thought that I
just roll in there in the [ __ ] yeah yeah
III never really I never really went
through that but I remember once I was
newly famous after the office and there
was a trouble with a bill that kept
sending me the wrong [ __ ] bill I was
like - is it your phone or something so
I called up and I thought I'm gonna
really [ __ ] I was fuming right and I
waited and waited so I'm really agitated
now
so hello can help you I went yeah it's
the third time I see Oakland Toby
details I went Ricky Gervais she went oh
what from the office okay I said oh I
love that show and Cheer - what have you
went it's no big deal
I can't go crazy and someone it's like
in a restaurant right if if two people
are like waiting that annoys me so I'm
fuming I'm looking okay they're eating
now do they just strumming on their
bread right and then one of them
recognizes me and they sort of go Oh big
fan that's it I can't I can't go we'll
stop [ __ ] chewing with your mouth
open your Pig I'm surprised how little
etiquette there is and I'm here but I
see at home you know and I can sneeze
into the air and dribble food and all
that right but in a restaurant I don't
know how people even waiters of profit
and they're gone I think what the [ __ ]
are you doing yeah did no one ever tell
you that is [ __ ] disgusting I don't
even understand like just walking down
the street how people just breathe out
of their mouths my mouth okay scuffling
huh like not doesn't know if you're
going the other rection they don't say
sorry No
and the wine you want to go what how
have you lived this long it's the
holding the door when they don't say
thank you it fantasies about dragging
them back through and slamming the
[ __ ] face
I know it's again it's that [ __ ]
rudeness it's that entitlement you know
but then I think well maybe they're
exactly what I do is I avoid those
situations I hate going through the door
holding the door you know I'd do it but
it's it's just awkward well don't expect
to thank you maybe you don't expect
nothing just do it and of course yeah we
don't get to thank you just repeat the
phrase to yourself hopefully as mom has
can sometimes think that a little um
just to your south rain like if you get
you get trolled on Twitter someone says
summer nasty then you look at their
timeline and you go oh my god this guy
should kill himself right could you
certainly realize it's like being
shouted at by a [ __ ] rat in a bin
right you can't get angry you know I
mean you've won and I think that you
know these people that walk around and
they think they don't know how to
breathe through their nose I think what
they've already lost I don't need to get
I don't need to punish little things
you're like if you haven't figured out
how to shut your mouth when you're
walking there's no way that anything
you've got going on is gonna make it
won't do any good vs or out of you or
anything like that yeah oh yeah like
someone sort of got an annoying voice
that got a really annoying voice or they
laugh and they clap at the same time and
I'm giving them dirty looks and Janes
saying they don't know why you're
looking at them right now I think
looking at their go for Ricky Gervais he
look to me I better stop doing this [ __ ]
but they don't they just think you know
so I should know I want I want a ticket
police I want a report and some guys
ever say sorry you're you're not a voice
is so annoying you have to you have to
stop talking like that well more and
more people don't want it I mean it's
what we were talking about when you
first got here people don't you don't
want to call people out on their stuff
yeah so people go through life doing
these things that annoy everybody but
nobody's ever said anything to him well
I no idea but I I know I've got like we
were going past a
the other day in the car and I went all
that um that looks nice um Jamie went oh
we went there once I went all right
what's really she said yeah I'm we left
because you said there was a [ __ ] eating
bread well what else can you do when
there's a did you say that just to her
did you scream it people are on their
phones in public in places like that if
people just don't realize how hateable
they are when they're behaving in a way
that everybody kind of has to notice
what you're doing and it's unpleasant
for all of us
oh wow yeah you mean like talking loudly
I don't know how people like on a train
of summer there hi John yeah tell
Chandra to I think I want to tell some
too - why where they call with sign up
private things and you hear them yelling
and you're like I've heard I've been on
a train and they're yelling and I'm like
hopefully it'll just be quick and they
go no it's fine I'm on a train
everything's good and you're like oh my
god it's just gonna go on forever
yeah no going I'm worried that they were
thinking of bringing in mobiles on
planes because I feel and they just
talked about that yeah I that can't
happen no no no it's the one even though
Wi-Fi I don't like Wi-Fi on airplanes
why I just love the only oh god what
that was connected there was a woman on
the Osos first class doesn't even and
years ago there's a woman typing on a
thing so she's banging the keys you
don't need to bang the keys on the
modern laptop right but she had bangles
just playing the maracas anything annoys
we're like this is it this is first
class
it doesn't get any better than this once
right I got a regular driver he's
brilliant right it was freezing cold
really got a new job
you got a new jacket leather jacket
right and it was squeaking what can I do
you in answer so you can't tell some of
those jackets dudes okay
and I turned up that is jacket squeaking
it came from you doesn't like me
squeaking thinking for me maybe you
should not wear the check it's a little
loud it's bothering Ricky but it's like
I know it's my psychosis right now
there's a bunch of keys right and it was
in the car right and the keys were
rattling well no the car we're never get
any when you win you like things that I
just loved it the guy like it's probably
really happiest new jacket I know I'm
gonna wear to work I'm gonna wear it out
like this is my new jacket but now I
always either of my iPod with some noise
cancelling headphones or ear plugs
I sometimes carry earplugs just so it
takes down that I know I'm mental I know
you just put any earplugs
just in case someone's sniffing you know
I think cuz then I think if someone's
sniffing right and they're sitting in
there like that okay
that's once okay I look at them they
don't no one looking on right oh my god
I think and I think I've just remembered
something else I did once what did you
do Oh on a plane right there was this
guy right it's about 50 years old I
again first class right and he went like
that right did it once with it twice
right
and I said them I told you need a tissue
and what I said do you need a tissue
you went now when all you do because
you're going and I sat down and I
started over grated I think now I've got
the whole [ __ ] journey with this
bloke right and then I would sit - Jane
wife he's mafia or someone so now all my
bravery is gonna put a hit on you
exactly : to blow his nose no nose it's
not shy yes people killed for talking
about I know and it's just honestly I'm
a bag I'm getting better now though are
you because I sort of I go a bit Zen I
think of something else
so I straightaway think I try and think
about maybe either bloke sniffing but
maybe you've got bone cancer it all
these annoying but people who watch
things with volume on in part excusable
because that's that's obvious because
you say that's what headphones are for
yeah strange when people are in
speakerphone speakerphone yeah that's
ridiculous
it's insane no that's ridiculous because
that's willful there's no there's no
reason for act like that is note that
that's like that's not ambiguous we have
two minutes left by the way here's a
dilemma I was with a girl in a
restaurant who I really wanted to have
sex with she started facetiming oh no I
got a restaurant was new just a friend
of hers she FaceTime and I wanted to
[ __ ] her so I was trying to like I
wanted to go get off the [ __ ] fire
but I didn't say that I was like oh come
on talk to me and then she finally got
off the phone I was such a weasel that
was a humiliating aggressive thing were
you she didn't know how close she came
to not having sex with you of course I
did good yeah she wouldn't have gotten
the thrill of her life she wouldn't have
had a sweaty turtle on it for six
minutes she collected her feet